for Earth day this week you might
consider donating your food scraps as
Mary Jane beliesza shows us recycling
food is all part of one Farm's efforts
to cut down on food waste
on the outskirts of the Valley located
on the other side of the Apex landfill
is probably last night's thrown out
leftovers however these pounds of food
scraps don't go to waste as its
processed and turned into pig feed right
here the business is run by the Combs
family they own Las Vegas livestock
formerly known as RC Farms so we're on
average
processing about 30 tons daily of food
scraps so it's a very high amount Farm
manager Sarah Stallard says reducing
food waste is all about conserving the
resources we already have the desert is
not sustainable for us to grow crops to
feed Hogs so we're able to take what
would be a wasted product
um riding in landfills and be able to
basically re-enter it into the food
system this machine separates food from
its package such as yogurt cups or
mayonnaise packets before pasteurizing
the food once it's cooked and heated up
then it comes out that pipe into our
feed trucks which then head down there
and
eat the pigs Farm supervisor isai
Martinez says the entire operation takes
about 45 minutes from the time the
scraps are dumped to when it's finished
cooking I do this one time one time per
day or sometimes I'll do it every other
day but it's a process like I said I'll
I'll be up here for three four five
hours in a single day
cooking not only do they collect food
scraps from local restaurants and
casinos but they're encouraging the
community to donate their food scraps
too very unique and why my grandfather
started it here in Vegas is just because
of the casinos and and the way that
Vegas is set up there's a lot of food in
one Central Area